el lanzamiento de la misión artemis ha
sido cancelada por segunda vez en los
ingenieros de la Administración Nacional
de aeronáutica y el espacio de Estados
Unidos la NASA a pesar de haber estado
trabajando intensamente en las últimas
horas no han podido solucionar los
problemas con una fuga de hidrógeno en
uno de los motores que afectaba también
a la ventilación es el mismo problema
del lunes cuando estaba previsto su
lanzamiento ya desde la NASA habían
alertado que no había garantía al 100%
de que se pudiera realizar este
lanzamiento del cohete Durante este
sábado porque lo querían tener todo
controlado Este es un vuelo de prueba
sin tripulación lo que significa que
ahora es el momento de revisar todo al
milímetro y ver los problemas que
podrían surgir durante una misión con
personal a bordo ya que este tipo de
ensayos no Se podrían poner en práctica
con personas en su interior ya que
podría poner en riesgo la vida de los
astronautas pese a los imprevistos las
miradas de medio mundo
vuelto a poner aquí en la plataforma
espacial de despegue en ciudades como
estas en titusville la más cercana a las
instalaciones de la NASA más de 200.000
personas se han congregado Aprovechando
que es sábado y que muchos están
Disfrutando del día del fin de semana
largo por el día del trabajo todos
tenían la esperanza de ver salir al
cohete para regresar a la luna 50 años
después una misión cuyo objetivo es el
de tener una presencia continuada en la
superficie lunar conocer el terreno para
luego enviar seres humanos a Marte Ese
es el objetivo final de momento Hay
posibilidad de despegue el 5 o el 6 de
septiembre si no se hace Entonces el
vuelo hacia la luna con artemis se
retrasaría hasta por lo menos el 19 de
septiembre